- You guys have turned the medical
reaction series into a total hit.
But I wanted to take
things to the next level,
so I partnered with the
folks from the TV show
The Resident to give
you a behind-the-scenes
look of the set,
interview one of the main actors
from the show, Manish Dayal,
and even tried my hand at acting.
They offered me an Emmy, I was like,
"Chill for a second."
(slow techno music)
I'm here with Manish Dayal,
who plays Dr. Devon Pravesh.
- Amazing doctor, gifted
doctor, five stars.
- Do you ever have difficulty on set?
There's a word you don't know,
how do you prepare for that?
- Oh, all the time.
(Mike laughs)
I mean, every script,
there are these words.
I often will look at the procedure
or what the word means on YouTube first,
and then I have sort of a visual.
There's one in particular
that really threw us last
year was naegleria fowleri.
- Naegleria fowleri.
- That's right.
- What's your view
or how has your view changed
of doctors now playing a doctor?
- Oh, I've always had
great respect for doctors.
The dedication, the commitment.
I have an even greater
respect for just the amount
of knowledge that doctors have
to retain and exercise every day.
It's immense.
- It's crazy,
because on top of having to know,
even your character, well-researched,
well-studied Harvard, knows a
lot of textbook information,
but then applying it in a practical sense
to another human being who's so complex,
that's such a challenge that people
normally don't highlight.
- There's a stage of
being a doctor in school
and outside of the hospital and then
you see doctors inside of the hospital
and what changes and how they're applying
textbook information,
academics, to practice
and it can be discombobulating.
Especially for Devon in the first season.
- Yeah, big time.
- What is the first
question you ask in code?
- Rhythm.
- We're on set right now.
You have multiple sets here.
You have the ER, OR.
Do you mind giving us a little tour
so we can sort of break down
how realistic this is
from a medical standpoint?
- Absolutely, no problem at all.
This right here is the ER.
We have 10 trauma bays here.
This is the nurses station.
- Yup, very accurate, might I add.
- Yeah, tell about what this is--
- Well, so initially
when I walked in here,
I was really impressed with
the attention to detail.
This is really cool to
show people at home,
the Post-its are legit.
Our computers--
- Legit Post-its.
- I didn't post this.
- Our computers are covered in Post-its.
- These are--
- Do the phones work?
How accurate--
- Oh, no, no.
- Don't look at these.
Patient privacy, Dane, what are you doing?
- Don't violate HIPAA, right?
- (laughs) Yeah, HIPAA, see?
He knows about HIPAA.
- Yeah.
- This is very accurate.
The beds look like they're
functional, the rails go up.
So this is--
- Yes, so we--
- This is very realistic.
- During a scene though dude,
so basically, we'll be
doing a scene and like--
- (laughs) Figuring out how to lower it.
- And then it doesn't work!
- This blood pressure
reading is a little crazy,
91 over 132 so this patient--
- What's wrong with that patient?
- This is not a live
person's blood pressure.
- The lower number--
- This person's dead.
- Yeah, this person's dead.
- This person is
absolutely dead.
This is the ICU.
We have a--
- This is very accurate
as well.
- Is it?
- Yeah, the rooms need to be
able to be isolation rooms.
The way that they're spread
apart is very accurate.
The nursing station being in the middle,
to have the view of all the
rooms is very important.
This chart is actually
really realistic, also.
Because when the patient is in the ICU,
they can develop something
known as delirium
where they don't know where they are
and looking at this can help them a lot.
They'll know who their nurse
is, who their doctor is.
It also is helpful to some
of the nurses taking care
of the patients to know what
they're supposed to be eating.
Honestly, if I walked in here
and I had no idea where I was prior,
I would say, I'm definitely in a hospital.
There's no way I would
say that this is a set.
- Now, we're gonna move to the OR.
- Let's move to the OR.
- Which is where all the blood
and the guts and the gore...
(Mike laughs)
- [Dr. Mike] Which was that
first scene of the entire show.
- That's where we're goin' right now.
- That's when the mistake happened.
I got chills during that part.
- Really?
- 'Cause I've seen
medical errors happen in front of me.
Maybe not to that extent,
but I remember, it brought
up all these feelings
of what I felt during those moments.
It made you feel as if you
were there, so it was--
- And especially as a
young doctor when you have,
when the responsibility to your job,
but also your bosses and
the people who employ you.
- A lot of conflicting interests.
Wow.
- This is the ICU room.
- Hello!
- I mean, there's so much
blood on this floor usually.
You wouldn't even be able to walk.
We have this machine, the
blood-splatter machine.
There's a pump that
looks like a helium pump.
And attached to it is a clear tube
that gets hidden under the clothing,
or taped behind the arm of the patient.
So when it's time for the blood to squirt,
they pump it, and the blood
just squirts up.
- Squirts out.
- And usually my character's
behind that glass, just
watching, 'cause I don't...
- 'Cause you're not a surgical resident.
- I'm not a surgeon, I wish!
- You do rotate, right?
You have to learn experience?
- We do rotate, I mean,
right now, I'm in the ER and if I'm lucky,
I'll get to move to
surgery, but we'll see.
This is another, here, we'll go in here.
- Oh, wow.
- In the next episode, which
we start shooting on Monday,
it's the Halloween episode.
And everyone is tasked
with a different job.
But there's this big Halloween party,
so the doctors all go
to the Halloween party.
My character's left in the ER
to treat this arm that comes in.
What up, what up!
- These lights are legitimate.
You see this little covering on the light
is to make sure that
even when you touch it,
you still maintain your sterility.
Sunshine is the one that generally
gives you the guidance on
mistakes that you're making.
- Yes.
She's our medical wizard, yeah.
- How often is she saying,
"Guys, you have to stop the scene
"because the technique is wrong here."
Does that happen often?
- Well, she won't stop
it while we're taking.
She'll wait until we call cut--
- Got it.
- To come in with a note,
and we'll implement it and shoot it again.
- Awesome, yeah, 'cause--
- Because there's always
pieces they can take.
- How many cameras are going at--
- Three, and sometimes four.
- Wow.
We watched them film a scene for Season 2,
not gonna spill any
secrets but it's incredible
how many things are
happening simultaneously.
There's multiple cameras moving around,
actors, actresses, extras.
It blew my mind how much needs to happen
in order for one scene to get taken
in the perfect way.
Who is this gentleman?
- [Manish] This is, let's see here.
I have no clue who this is.
- And then this is the viewing room?
- There's a scene in the first episode
where we're all viewing a
very complicated surgery.
If you're an internist or
someone not allowed in there...
- Medical students?
- Medical students can
hang out in here.
- So medical students at home,
this is where you'd be
hanging out watching the
operation go live.
The signs are accurate in
terms of which way to go.
They're complicated just
like they are in real life.
After getting the tour of the entire set,
I really wanted to know
firsthand what it would be like
to be an actor on a medical drama.
Manish was kind enough to do a little
improv session with me.
- Hi, I'm Dr. Pravesh.
What's your name?
- Hi, doctor. What took so long?
I don't understand.
I've been here for an hour.
- I'm sorry, you see all these
patients we have here now.
What brings you into the ER today?
- My stomach's been killing me, doc.
- Okay.
- I don't want
to be frank here, but my
stool, it's disgusting.
- Wow, how long have
you had these symptoms?
- Like, 24 hours.
I came back from Mexico.
I don't know if it's ZIKA.
What am I doing here, doc?
Is this a, it's a tumor.
- No, it's not a tumor.
We'll get to the bottom of that.
- Oh, my stomach. I like
your stethoscope, by the way.
- Oh, thank you.
- Matte black, it's a great choice.
- It is, yeah.
They sponsor my practice.
- Doctor, why are you
listening to my lungs
when I told you my stomach hurts?
(laughing)
- I don't understand.
You see, I can't act.
I'm sorry, I'm gonna
stick to being a doctor.
All right, Manish, we appreciate you
taking out the time showing
us behind the scenes,
allowing me to show off
my horrible acting chops.
What grade do you give me?
- I give you a solid A.
- Wow.
- That's too kind.
- Yes.
- He's obviously lying,
but again thank you for
taking out the time.
Everyone, check out the season premier
of Season 2 of The Resident.
Stay happy and healthy.
(slow techno music)